aunque baiden reitera que eeuu es un
aliado de israel también ha dicho que
quiere ser un intermediario con los
palestinos esto luego de cuatro años en
los que donan son claramente fue pro
israelí trasladando por ejemplo su
embajada en israel a jerusalén la ciudad
disputada según su análisis cuál es el
papel ahora de la casa blanca en el
conflicto palestino-israelí y qué tan
determinante es esta visita al respecto
muchísimas gracias mala cara pues es muy
determinante es una jugada estratégica
en un momento crítico del mundo y del
medio oriente pero es que además de
intermediario hoy lo expresó
públicamente si no estoy mal fue la
reunión que tuvo con el señor gesoc o
con el ministro de defensa y dijo que es
definitivamente la única solución que ve
que es la de los dos estados
desde luego garantizando la seguridad de
israel y recibió también un montón de
elogios de quien fuera antes de ser el
embajador de eeuu ante la onu que vive
en nueva york que lo nombró como
sionista y dijo que el señor rey baiden
que es la décima vez que visita desde
que inició su carrera política por allá
no 70 que visita a israel que es un
americano más convencido del pueblo
israelí o sea por lo menos de entrada y
una sinergia y es probable que eso
redunde en su proyecto de los dos
estados más adelante bueno ya pesar de
esta sinergia hay una clara diferencia
entre bailén y trump
al tema del acuerdo nuclear con irán que
limita la fuerza de producción de ese
país en su viaje por medio oriente
bailén dijo que no descarta el uso de la
fuerza para evitar que irán obtenga las
armas nucleares que gana con esto
el baile en lo que está buscando es
ganar adeptos para la campaña electoral
que viene ahora lo que llaman estarán en
eeuu y está utilizando
ambas figuras no porque por un lado dice
que el peor error que cometió throne fue
haberse retirado del acuerdo y lo dijo
hoy en israel al llegar pero por el otro
lado dice que está dispuesta a usar la
fuerza entonces es mensaje como para
satisfacer a ambos y tuvo una reunión
más o menos amable con netanyahu con
quien no tuvo una relación cuando era
vicepresidente pero todo está por verse
y da la intención de que más tiene un
interés político y sobre todo del
acercamiento con los estados del golfo
pérsico por el tema del petróleo lo que
está pasando con rusia